I do think the last time you came on the
show you pretty pretty blatantly was
like I'll [ __ ] your girl yeah I did like
if you're out there
and I meet your girl I'll [ __ ] her yeah
I'll get out yeah yeah no yeah I was I
was like two years ago yeah
I was like yo I'll [ __ ] your girl yeah
I'm a different person now bro and you
were talking to anyone specifically you
were just talking to the world yeah like
period though like what's going like I
want Lotto like two years ago okay like
before I got in a relationship bro like
what was gonna stop a [ __ ] from [ __ ]
my girl
nothing
wait a minute wait a minute what was
going to stop somebody from [ __ ]
[ __ ] my girl if I had a girl like at
the time right what was gonna or even my
girl right now what's gonna stop him
from [ __ ] her
her love for you if she wanna [ __ ] them
no
um
they gonna [ __ ] her
so if you're a girl
yeah if your girl once so if your girl
want to [ __ ] me right what's gonna stop
me there's nothing that's gonna stop her
from doing it or vice versa what was
gonna stop me but
do you draw like old twosie with old
Tuesday would he draw the line if it was
a Married Girl
or is it [ __ ] it's free for all marriage
ring your husband can be a overseas is
that like a sin I don't know I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm atheist so I
don't care about none of that [ __ ] I
don't care sin no sin whatever what are
we talking about
but would you have like a coat of
conduct or be like you know what you're
married
or that make it even better because then
because then if it's a merry girl you're
[ __ ] with you know for sure she don't
want it to get out so it's a lot less
sloppy no ethically it's a little more
[ __ ] up but even if you was married I
was it was it was taxing you were you
you were taking down the married yeah
bro I didn't care bro you didn't care no
nice living life breathing air not
playing Fair